trevor story he's got some experience
naturally against arietta two free one
of the two hits a home run
high fly ball deep left field trevor
story
has hit it
off the bat he clicked it's 104 miles an
hour off but it was a launch angle 43
degrees so that's bringing some rain
schwendel hits a pop fly shallow center
falling in there for a base hit
bloop single for the cubs first baseman
frank schwendel he'll take it with a big
smile on his
and face is another terrific pit same
spot jake ariana to connor joe
connor joe hits this ball to deep right
and
it is
gone in half went to the wall and then
was looking for a ricochet that never
happened
opposite field homer for connor joe his
third of the year
all time the ball is in flight my mind
was saying joe joe joko
and that's strike three so area never
moved to bat
second strikeout for sensatella
[Applause]
he struck out four in a row i don't know
if i've seen him do that
this is going to be a tough chance for
alcantara
[Applause]
another leg hit
for tapia
not going rogers bounces one to the
right side he's got a 12 game hitting
streak and quickly to the baseball is he
in half so ryan mcmahon to hit
this is off the glove of wisdom tapi is
going to end up scoring rogers will go
first to third three nothing colorado
big man with his 56th rv out
stats swung on it that's fine
in a row
that has to be a first for senzitella
break this one down
he's got it
six in a row
here's sam hilliard sam hit a hard
ground ball into the shift his first
time
this ball crushed
take a good look you won't see it for
long
oh my goodness
i may have broken something in the
second deck
good way to start his second 100 games
in the big leagues
wow i mean a 508 slugging percentage
through the first 100 games for hilliard
which is eighth in rocky's history
so what two from arietta
and that's off at jake and there's going
to be a base hit for
daza
there's a base hit for dog
and daza who runs well is going to
sprint to
third base and a lot of swings at the
first or second pitch that they see
today from jake
[Music]
throw down to third and they catch daza
off the base contreras
with the gun down the wisdom
there's a rip for a base hit
from j-dog
it's actually andrew romine hitting for
arietta here
and uh his upward tick continues
he's hit now in four of the five games
that we've seen him
and he gets rafael ortega a shot he's
one for two with a single a seven game
hit streak two on with two out and
here's the one two to rafael ortega
[Applause]
rafael sends that one out to shallow
right and that's going to drop and a run
will score
rbi single for ortega scores fergus
wilson contreras is now the tying run to
the plate picked one off throwing
another one out trying to steal
first pitch swinging
opposite way off the top of the fence
one run is in
ortega coming home and he will dive in
head first safely and contreras will
motor all the way around to third and
it's a one run game
and the two out rally for the cubs
here's ian happ
swings and lines one in the left for a
basic thai ball game as contreras comes
in the score
and just like that
4-4 cubs and rockies
this is up the middle and brennan rogers
has another knock three hits last night
two more today
he now has a 12-game hitting streak
going that'll bring up story in addition
to the home run you just saw from story
in the first he hit a fly ball to right
in the third
well hit right center field and it is
gone
second home run of the day for trevor
story
and the rockies back on top six to four
it's gonna be a story
second homer today he's got 15 now
he is so well connected over the last
couple days story's gotten slain
phony reaches and that will drop in for
extra bases
around a second
the bodhi battle bot
six to four colorado leading the cubs
with a leadoff double from bodhi have a
man at second
in this sixth inning frank schwendell
and that will drop in for a base hit
bodhi on his horse he'll head for home
and it's back to a one-run game
schwendell with the rbi single
what he did
then a base runner on for contreras
here's the 3-2
runner was going
and sliding in safe
1-1 to wisdom that one's a flare shot
towards rogers he gloves it charging but
he throws to first and he gets his man
carlos estevez back to back scoreless
outings he'll try to make it three
straight
2-2 to fargus swore not missed and a
strong inning from a step-ups one two
three in the eighth
hard with a record of five and five a
4.33 era 16 saves and 22 chances here's
another 02.
swung on and missed so daniel strikes
out
sergio alcantara what out the ninth
inning
and this is
and the rockies take the series
[Applause]